[Music]
have you wanted an alternative to use
NHL series one where it was a bit more
like NHL 94 on the Genesis and SNES well
you're about to get what you want
as an M rated arcade hockey game is set
to hit ps4 and PC in March I'm mat this
is a GameSpot news update and make sure
to LIKE and subscribe for more coverage
of the good old hockey game old-time
hockey is an arcade hockey game set in a
1970s bush league most players don't
wear helmets and there are a ton of
fights and if you've played hockey games
on a 16-bit console then it'll look
intimately familiar it features several
different control options including a
more modern style a two-button scheme
and a beer mode which lets you play with
one hand for obvious reasons on top of
all that you can play the game in local
co-op or a competitive multiplayer but
unfortunately there is no online mode
old-time hockey releases for ps4 and PC
on March 28 the arcade sports game is
set to hit the Xbox one sometime between
April and June while at Nintendo's
switch version is coming at a later date
we'll report back when those dates are
revealed but if you want more sports
action right now check out our feature
walkthrough of MLB the show 17
Oh